so what is the zero of a polynomial the
phrase sounds confusing let us try to
understand it consider the polynomial P
of x equals x plus 3 now here's a very
simple question based on this polynomial
what value of x will make P of X equal
to zero that is the value of the
polynomial equal to zero what do I use
in place of X such that X plus 3 equals
zero since this is a simple linear
polynomial we can easily say that for X
equal to minus 3 we get the value for
the polynomial as minus 3 plus 3 equal
to 0 so minus 3 in place of X gave us a
0 so minus 3 is called the zero of the
polynomial P of X remember zero of the
polynomial is a number which when
substituted in place of X makes the
value of the polynomial zero generally
the number of zeros of a polynomial
equals the degree of the polynomial in
this particular case the degree of the
polynomial is 1 which is why we have 1 0
which is minus 3 what is the general
form of these kinds of polynomials with
degree 1 we will see that next
you